joining me now is Stephen Miller former
senior advisor to president Trump and
founder of America First legal also with
me is Lieutenant Chris Olivares who's a
Texas Department of Public Safety
spokesman Stephen let's start with you
on the point of these Venezuelans almost
a half million getting temporary
protected status
first of all what is that is it really
temporary and is this legal
no no one no it's not temporary it's not
legal and it's not justified by any of
the circumstances happening today
temporary protective status is for for
example let's say you have an illegal
alien from a country that is in the
middle of an active volcano so you can't
Deport them that week to that country so
you might give them temporary protective
status temporary protective status is a
form of amnesty it gives you legal
presence it gives you a work permit and
because of the way our country works it
will be renewed indefinitely it will be
a lifelong forever amnesty and
ultimately Democrats will agitate to
give everybody who has temporary
protective status full citizenship and
voting rights and chain migration in the
United States the message not just to
Venezuela by giving illegal aliens from
their amnesty but the message to the
whole of the entire developing world is
come to America Joe Biden will not only
escort you into the country to the city
of your choice but Joe Biden will give
you lifetime residency in this country
the purpose of this initiative is to
accelerate the already record-breaking
illegal immigration into this country
Chris now we've been showing video of
illegals crawling under the barbed wire
at our border to get in I mean it's
pretty easy to do that but you said that
you caught Customs and Border Patrol
agents cutting the wire themselves
apparently to facilitate the crossings
into our country what's the story there
you know Laura this is something that
we've seen reasons with border patrol
yeah with board Patrol agents cutting
the Constantino wire that we have placed
as a state as a deterrent to try to
prevent illegal border crosses now this
not the fault of the border patrol
agents the field agents they're doing
tremendous work under just challenging
circumstances but they're getting orders
from the administration to do this and
it puts these agents in a predicament
now where they're being forced by the
administration to go against what they
completely signed up for and that is to
protect our borders and to focus on
criminal activity not to cut concertina
wire and to allow Mass illegal
immigration you know into our state
especially in Texas and that's what
we're seeing play out and it puts you
these agents in a predicament in
situations where they shouldn't be and
it all falls on poor leadership that's
why we need strong leadership we saw
that prior to 2021 we did not experience
more experience now at the border we
have thousands that are coming across
you have criminals that are coming
across suspected terrorists armed gunman
cartel gunmen that are coming across our
borders unimpeded the Border was to
secured prior to 2021 it's a complete
disarray right now and we need strong
leadership back so we can take our
border back and secure it I mean people
have to really wrap their minds around
this temporary protected status decision
by by President Biden um because that's
a half million people
and people around the world hear this
and they are it's sold relentlessly on
Instagram and Facebook and other forms
of social media that there are free work
permit Stephen I know you've seen the
posting so have I their free work
permits just get here and and you know
you'll be taken care of this is going to
be a crush of humanity more than the
tens of thousands we've seen just in the
last a week and a half or so at our
Southern border Stephen this is a this
is a human Financial cultural
catastrophe and I would say National
Security in safety catastrophe for this
country and they want more of it why
it is a wrecking ball to every feature
and part of American society that half a
million Laura that's half the population
of Montana in the blink of an eye are
now on a road to American citizenship
and they also just announced they're
going to be giving TPS to Afghanistan
temporary protected status and you heard
that ridiculous list from mayor Adams
listening basically every country on the
globe this is opening Pandora's Box
saying that we have a categorical policy
in this country again not only admitting
you not only using border patrol to
bring you to the city of your choice but
we will regularize you we will make you
permanent in this country what is the
objective you ask I think is quite clear
they do not believe that their agenda
and their results their San Francisco
policies are sellable to the American
people to American citizens so the end
of the day they want to change the power
structure in this country because they
believe the poor workers from the
developing world brought in large
numbers who will not be in the middle
class who will not be able to pay their
own way will become dependent on the
Democratic Party Machine for health care
for education and for sustenance so they
believe those numbers bring them more
power and that's what this is It's
fundamentally an attack on Democracy
yeah Chris the amazing thing about this
as well is that the Democrats response
to this is no what we're actually seeing
isn't happening
I give you congresswoman Debbie
Wasserman Schultz
do I think the border is out of control
no I think there's a pretty orderly
process that people go through to be
processed at the border of seeking
Asylum what you see is different than
what happens in in actuality so if
someone is picked up at the border
obviously that begs the question that
they're not streaming across the border
and escaping into our country
Chris what's your message to her
you know that's that's a blatant lie to
the American people we know for a fact
their process right now their strategy
is inhumane when you have thousands that
are streaming across our border crossing
a river having chilled across the river
just just yesterday alone Laura we
recovered a three-year-old little boy
from The River who drowned the week
before that a 10 year old that drowned
in the same area in Eagle Pass how can
they say that's Humane their process
right now their strategy the
Administration has completely just
completely created a disaster at our
border that's why we continue to see
these thousands of illegal immigration
immigrants coming across our border and
there's no stopping it right now Laura
Chris did the buoys help at all
or I mean the the sheer numbers I've
never seen anything like this this is
this is a slow-moving purposeful
encouraged invasion of the country
happening that's what's happening
and we can say it's not what it's
happening or that's that's rude to say
no what else do you call it I mean
that's what it is but it's it but people
are being told to come essentially
so that's what's happening but did those
buoys do much or
well Lord they have and again keep in
mind it's only a thousand feet that we
have in the river and every single
person that you see coming across and
that footage there and the drownings
that have been taking place have been
taking place far away from the barrier
now earlier on that's what we would see
the majority of illegal immigrants
Crossing but we were able to shut down
that area and of course you know now
there's a legal battle against Governor
Abbott in the state of Texas and what
we're trying to do so another challenge
that we have to face is not only going
after criminal organizations and trying
to deter illegal immigration but now
we're having to go against the federal
government our own government that's
trying to stop us to try to put some
type of deterred measures in place to
prevent unauthorized border crossings
yeah uh we gotta go but Stephen just
just very very quickly we're about to do
a big segment on Ukraine okay I know a
lot of people care about Ukraine if only
the senators in leadership positions
cared much about what was happening to
our country as they do about Ukraine we
probably could have already put the
pressure on this Administration to shut
this down correct Stephen
if our border got the attention and
focus from the political class in DC for
even one week that Ukraine has every
week this thing would be shut down and
my plea to Congress as you do these
funding bills is use every Authority at
your disposal to stop this resettlement
or the consequences will truly be
irreversible Stephen and Chris thank you
so much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else